يستمر الاضراب العام في عشرات المدن
الايرانيه بمشاركه شعبيه تعتبر واسعه
واعلان بعض الشخصيات العامه المشهوره من
فنانين ورياضيين المشاركه به رغم
التهديدات التي اطلقتها السلطات الايرانيه
بانها ستحاسب بشكل صارم وقاس جميع من
يشارك به اضراب ترافق مع بعض المظاهرات
جاءت تتويجا لما يقارب من ثلاثه اشهر من
الاحتجاجات والمظاهرات اليوميه وصفت بغير
المسبوقه في مدتها وانتشارها وزخمها هزت
اركان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه العقائديه
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه تشهد اضرابات متفرقه
لكنها غير منهجيه والسبب الرئيسي في ذلك
هو ان الطبقه الوسطى الايرانيه لا تملك
الاموال ووسائل الاضراب اللازمه للبقاء في
المنازل وعدم الذهاب للعمل لكسب العيش
السلطات الايرانيه تتهم الولايات المتحده
وحلفاء الغربيين وكذلك الجماعات الكرديه
المتميزه في الخارج بانهم المحرضون وتصيفه
باعمال شغب وقد اعلن الحرس الثوري
الثلاثاء توقيف اثني عشر شخصا بتهمه
الانتماء الى مجموعه من المخربين على صله
بدول اوروبيه السلطه القضائيه الايرانيه
اعلنت انها قضت باعدام خمسه اشخاص بعد ما
اودينوا بالتورط في مقتل عنصر من الباسيج
خلال الاحتجاجات التي تجتاح البلاد
مجموعات حقوقيه تتهم النظام الايراني
بانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان بما في ذلك
اعدامات خارج نطاق القانون وعمليات خطف في
الخارج وفرض الاقامه الجبريه على رعايه
اجانب لتصبح ايران البلد الاكثر تطبيقا
لعقوبه الاعدام في العالم بعد الصين بحسب
منظمه العفو